french fry
i had to start with the food but it's
all about the drinks here at atomic
liquors i'm joined by chris again and we
have our bartender friend over here
devin chris we got a lot of cocktails on
the menu what are we going to be making
over here so i got devin pouring right
now a strawberry fields it's a drink
that's been there since our day one it's
got strawberry flavored beef eater pink
gin it also has campari fresh lemon
elderflower and a little strawberry
candy on top it's adjoined with some
other awesome classic atomic cocktails
that we have there we have our hunter s
mash that uh pays pays trim
tribute to the man that used to hang out
with us and we have a local sour beer
there on the end
as a no to the note to the sour saturday
that we're going to have here in a
couple days yeah what is the sour
saturday tell me about that so it's a
historic beer fest party that has been
here at atomic for years we're doing a
tribute to it by offering half off all
of our sour beers for all day saturday
oh that sounds like so much fun and
these all look so refreshing for summer
and that one has a sweet treat on top
which one is your favorite devin uh the
strawberry fields for sure every time
and you have a lot of regulars that come
in through the bar hang out here every
day what's it like to just be around
having fun hanging out with the usuals
it's honestly my favorite thing to do
every every day even when i come in and
i'm tired or they hype me up every day
and they keep me company even on my
slower times well this bar has really
stood the test of time and i gotta say
the french fries are delicious tell me
about the food i love if you can see
here it says atomic on the bun what is
this
if you wanted to have a burger the
hunter s thompson way you could get our
old crow bourbon bacon burger with an
egg on it
oh my gosh oh it's delicious okay we
have tacos over here too yeah for our
plant-based friends we have a couple of
vegan portobello mushroom tacos with
some fresh salsa verde ah awesome well
i'm just gonna sit here have some french
fries enjoy the strawberry cocktails you
guys thank you so much happy 70 years
it's a huge accomplishment be sure to
come check out atomic liquors in
downtown las vegas send it back to you
just wiping my mouth because my mouth is
watering you got to eat with chef todd
english and all your mouth is watering
yes